and I'm um I'm proud of you man I think
you can have kids can I say something
um why money now I'm gonna hire Nanny
we'll be outside of that I think that a
perfect partner for you is someone who
understands that you'll like love your
children a lot but maybe will not
um participate in the day-to-day
um stuff like as intensely
like
yeah but that's what my dad did but I
mean like you know it's I mean even if
you think about like our animals right
you buy them great food you go splurge
on them right but you're not doing the
feeding the pooping the Vets the
difficult stuff like you're you're very
efficient at some parts I do play you do
play I love I love hard on them
yeah yeah but it's like um here and
there it's not like everyday
um I don't think that's not fun stuff I
don't think that's a good dad
um because I think my memories of my dad
were um he never drove me to school he
never picked me up he never
um
took me to the game played ball any of
those things and he did provide
um you know without his temper and his
anger issues there were moments of Love
there but um
you do grow up resenting the fact
they're just just there's this whole
section of childhood I just never was
able to experience
and I don't want to do that you know I
think that's important to like pick up
your kid up and ask him how his day is I
think so and all those things yeah so um
I think of all things to like just be
emotionally available because you could
do all of the providing and all the
chain you know getting them to where
they need to be but if you're not able
to just be if you're emotionally
neglectful and you don't acknowledge
that your kid is like this thing with
feelings I think that's the most
detrimental to a kid yeah
I believe so but that's where I feel
like you'd shine you're somebody who
really gives really good advice you're
able to you know talk and work through
feelings difficult ones yeah I mean I
think that um I I could teach my kid
um things obviously that I learned from
being in 12 scripts stop groups all my
life and you know I've always asked
older dudes you know throughout my life
you know what do I do what's the best
way to handle the situation what's your
perspective even if I agree or just
disagree you know I'm I've always been
like I've always wanted to learn how to
live life you know and um because when
you're a kid you're not especially when
you're a kid that speaks English and
your parents don't speak English
you're getting all your information
through media like the television or
little glimpses you would see with your
friend's parents right but you never
know how to do anything you know you
don't even know what to do with your
emotions or What feelings are that's
been so hard to have like a difficult
feeling and know that you have to go
outside of your parents to kind of like
figure that out
I mean that's why I was blessed at 17 I
was able to go to meet AAA meetings
because it's like I went to these men's
meetings with way older people like
lawyers and plumbers and people have
their own companies and we would go on
these Retreats when I was a junior in
high school I went on to that Monastery
with like 30 men and we stayed at a
monastery and I remember I stayed in a
room with this guy named Bruce he was a
lawyer he had his own law law firm and
he had a mustache from a thick mustache
and I was a high school
and I would just lay in bed like but
there were bunk beds or something and
Bruce would be above and this is a 50
year old man at the time and I would go
ask him things about life and and about
relationships and you know alcoholism
and he would like I would listen to
everything he said you know so I was
lucky in that way but anyway um it's not
the funniest podcast we've ever done but
it's the best
you think so I think so that's it is
there anything
um in the new year that you are looking
forward to or you feel like you want to
um
change